est-ce que vous et vous est déjà arrivé
un truc de ouf à l'antenne jauron vous
ai dit ma pompe a pas forcément on ce
thème là mais un truc qui vous a
vraiment mis mal ou un truc qui a fait
que vous avez failli rater une émission
vous paramétrez le quoi et même ben
justement à l'époque j'avais totalement
perdu ma voix et c'est emmerdant avait
toute une série d'enregistrements
version pallice non mais elle est pas
terrible mais sauf que j'avais plus de
voix donc comment voulez-vous faire dans
ce qu'ils sont ils ont appelé quelqu'un
pour faire des piqûres vous savez de
courtisols ouais et j'ai pas retrouvé ma
voix donc on a annulé le tournage la
baisse était plutôt content la
production mais
c'est vrai moi c'était un gros problème
les invités étaient là et tout c'était
un drame oui alors non plus vous
inquiétez plus c'était pire oui plastic
bertrand moi j'ai une horrible shit
attaque pendant l'émission quoi il ya
quoi vous une envie d'aller aux
toilettes ça va d'une chute attaque
l'anglais est donc en fait je me suis
dit et en fait
elle est survenue à 20h48 au retour pur
et c'était un jeudi je me suis monté à
une demi heure l'émission se termine à
21h15 et j'avais oublié vous faisiez un
prime derrière je suis mort via la pub
avant le prime et à 21h12 audit à long
manche et tout de suite sans plus
pendant deux heures
j'étais mal et je voulais partir mais
c'est un débat très sérieux donc voilà
c'est pas vrai mais je n'arrivais plus à
marcher après c'est un drame non
vraiment les équipes s'en souviennent
[Musique]
sur france 3 que j'animais une émission
testimoniale et il y avait 1
c'était un témoignage très très sérieux
très grave très et
la personne fait une phrase un peu
malheureuse et j'avais dans mon oreille
parce que parfois on a des producteurs
dans l'oeil qui fait un jeu de mots sur
le truc en question et j'étais très très
très fatiguée et du coup moi j'ai
tendance à très vite partir en fou rire
est là mais je sens que le fou rire
monte monte monte et les gens pleurent
sur le plateau est entre vraiment dans
des situations ce n'était pas le moment
du tout j'avais les larmes qui coulaient
comme ça et j'essaie de me retenir et de
parler et du coup s'est rendu compte que
voilà et donc ça a été mais la demi
heure la plus horrible de ma vie parce
que les gens j'avais peur qu'on se dise
mais elle est complètement insensible et
complètement c'est pas possible et je
compte vous pleuriez de tristesse la
tristesse avait alors qu'en fait je me
suis mordu au sens je me suis rendu au
sens pur je me suis pas ce que je
pouvais pas c'était pas possible moi tu
deviens gens non j'entends
c'est pas bien ça me faisait penser une
anecdote
[Rires]
est ce que vous voulez que j'appelle
peut-être des médecins mais vous avez
vos se passeront leurs rires non c'est
vrai qu'on vous n'êtes pas bien un truc
on va demander ce qui vous achète du
spasme lumbres est-ce que je resterai
jusqu'au bout non vraiment qu'est ce qui
se passe
quand je faisais la star ac oui et non
parce que là j'avais acquis il est lent
savez quoi saïb à la vie de leur commune
ont du coup j'ai joué ce matin des
crampes je suis allé aux toilettes à
plusieurs reprises alors c'est délicat
du coup j'ai mangé du riz oui oui oui
voilà et ça passe pas bien sap attaque
un peu le cerveau la
[Rires]
sorgue on est en train de perdre son
phrasé la lorraine avec 7 et en plus
vous avez vous avez ça va oui vraiment
racontez nous votre histoire commence à
peine je faisais la stac bonsoir et
c'était bien les damnés prime mais on
avait quand même des grosses grosses
vedettes y aller qui bruno mars
amano marque sur la mi mars brenner
zizou
a reçu 1
[Rires]
il était avec du des tweaks en thèse
odieux
mais
alors oui et donc est en fait moi
j'avais une très grande loge la loge de
l'animateur et du pardon j'étais
animateur et lui reste à l'écouté et y
avait un toilette commun pour les deux
non il va aux toilettes je parviens déjà
tant il paraît qu'ils démarrent dès mai
qui sort des toilettes et là c'est une
infection n'ont jamais vu ça de ma vie
et du coup c'est horrible parce que ça
m'a cassé le personnage au risque que je
fais ça il est venu chanter après à côté
de moi tout je ne voyais pas le chanteur
jeu
[Applaudissements]
qui avait fait condamner un chiotte pour
le quart d'heure c'est horrible a
raconté le pauvre c'est parce qu'ils
avaient alors est-ce que c'était le trac
de me voir
ils avaient eu lieu pendant les
répétitions tu penses bien je vais
répéter à tout le monde mais j'adore moi
j'adore cet artiste away and omar samad
pendant la répétition il avait demandé à
ce que tout le monde sorte donc reste le
producteur et moi et il me regarde et me
dit le petit boulot aussi non les fous
si
[Rires]
l'animateur est alors alors alors j'ai
sorti aussi non oui pour qu'ils fassent
ça n'empêche ces machins le bug connard
non marc était un
grand artiste on peut être un grand
artiste est très mal d'être sûr que
c'est lui qui tournait à surnager jury
l'a ouvert la porte j'ai bien dit
monsieur avec d'une jeune rouillé peut
il est petit ah oui et ouvert la porte
et il était gêné et moi aussi vraiment
ah oui il a senti que c'était horrible
ça peut vraiment cassé ça peut vraiment
cassé un personnage sans bras mesures
annoncées tu vois un truc non mais en
clichy à moitié dans son lit au petit
ses dribbles à vous hier soir donc dans
l'émission j'étais malade à chaque
coupure pub non vraiment malade mais on
n'a plus vu que j'étais malade pendant
l'émission non non non j'étais malade
souvent malades
qui n'est pas bon non moi j'ai fait
tomber dans les pommes pendant aux
cyclades story à lanta tomber dans les
pommes avec ces termes à l'aise vim
pourquoi bah je sais pas un malaise
vagal à bas les voilages et je passe des
choses vont tourner dans les pommes non
c'est sûr vous avez pas une migraine
ophtalmique
ouais enfin faites vous avec vos yeux se
demander non ça soit passagère et il
veut refaire mais c'est delphine tuetey
tu reviens truc un truc si j'ai eu un
truc quand on était au kenya on a fait
un tournage au kenya parce qu'on faisait
là là là non la défense là la défense
des éléphants donc j'étais avec une dame
qui était d'une association et on
faisait le tournage et on était au kenya
et toutes les autres personnes c'était
des gens de kenya qui était vraiment sur
le terrain il perd impliqués ce n'est
pas grave ce qui se passait tous et nous
est le décalage horaire elle est
tellement fatigués on a commencé à faire
notre interview en se disant voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe est très grave
les éléphants et tout est là on est
parti en fous-rires à peu près pendant
20 minutes donc nous déjà on était génie
entre nous mais bon voilà on savait mais
tous les gens du kenya qui nous
connaissaient
didier èches vasco da s'attendait à ça
non mais pour l'instant de la turquie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai justin mais depuis deux mois
bruxelles invite quoi n'ont jamais
s'avoue déçu mais c'était pas pendant un
tournage ah oui je peux quand même le
dire alors j'étais avec des amis dans un
restaurant chinois d'ailleurs est
évidemment j'ai commencé à avoir mal au
ventre mais vraiment mal au ventre comme
des couteaux quoi genre carrément je
faisais vraiment j'avais mal au ventre
vous avez accouché
j'avais tellement de pression dans le
ventre et du coup j'ai dit à ma copine
j'ai dit je peux pas rester à table et
tout machin du coup on allait dans les
toilettes carrément elle m'a mis au
sahel a dit écoute si tu te mets à plat
par terre ça va passer du coup j'étais
dans ses toilettes chinois par terre et
puis m lever les jambes comme ça et
parfois que les gens ils passaient mais
j'avais j'avais honte et puis en même
temps j'étais tellement
de salaire mais couché par terre dans le
poil est dégueulasse padois attention
c'est dégueu coucher par terre dans sa
toile et sans les mains vous n'avez rien
n'y avait rien faire savoir si on veut
et dans la saleté on se tourne vers des
mondes
et là on est sûr de la job est déçu mais
quoi moi j'en ai si vous vous des gens
mais j'ai été mangé chez des potes et ce
truc que je déteste les toilettes à côté
de la salle à manger pour quantifier qc
ca ils font les dessins de l'appartement
faire se disent la salle à manger le
coin de vie le canapé à côté du canapé
les gens partent rock m² célèbre faut-il
vous allez coucher d1 mais sans si vous
vivez dans un sens et non mais alors je
vais chercher deux potes et où il invite
des gens il y avait des idées des nanas
joly il y avait tout le monde et je
reste longtemps ils savent que je suis
resté longtemps il ya il est resté c'est
pas il n'a pas fait pipi et quand je
vais pour sortir jeu on se lève et on
regarde ce qu'on a fait toujours m'ont
dit on constate on dit oui une
constatation des dégâts
au salon autant dafu d'une partie
des coutumes partout partout partout et
je vais pour faire suppose pas là ça
arrive c'est chose à la vitesse donc pas
de chasse et des [ __ ] de merde elle
marche pas ça chasse d'eau
plus belle même dans la soirée il a fini
aux toilettes jean faut pas qu'elles
viennent
je cherche dollon jeudi me faut de l'eau
de l'eau jérôme faut que j'arrête ça
faut pas qu'elle ait voit ça et j'avais
mis du papier du papier pour bourrer la
salle ne marche pas et je dis à mon pote
la chose ne marche pas à travers me dit
non non la chanson marche pas je la
ferai paraît plus tard l'odeur mais à
mille odeurs je la porte tout le monde
m'a
[Rires]
s'appelle virginie la fille et virginale
arrive a dit je vais à l'autre et je
m'entends merde pas avec ça à vos potes
toilettes et c'est une horreur une
horreur une odeur je me suis tapé la
honte dans toute la soirée et virginale
tous les films mais je me suis fait
allumer ils ont ouvert la porte ils ont
dit faut qu'on sorte et du coup on est
parti manger une pizza en extérieur on
n'est pas
allés observer qu on alterne bonne
anecdote mauvaise et joël bonté ça va
être très rapide j'ai exactement le
problème à merde donc j'ai jamais eu une
gastro de ma vie leur histoire d'amour
dans un débat que sur scène mais
j'adorerais semble avoir cette sensation
mois trois étages aux philippines pas
une seule fois coire et et gemalto net
mais si je vais aux toilettes mais me
mets pas la même fréquence que vous
manifestement pas non mais nous on y va
comme tout le monde oui mais moi non
une fois par jour une fois par noront
quoi tous les quinze jours
les trois quatre jours du danger
si vous allez tous les quatre jours aux
toilettes un oui à peu près tu sembles
bouchon sans plus
c'est bizarre quand même que quatre
jours
vous allez tous les jours bien sûr c'est
une vo par deux fois par jour 1b naim et
moi j'ai tendance à ces importants
a pas y aller tout le temps non je
referai castel fois par jour mais c'est
important ça mon sens le matin et le
soir c'est important voilà le matin kron
et pardonnez moi
oui oui vous pas le matin et le soir moi
ça peut arriver que je fasse pas de
toute une journée mais par contre les
lendemains
[Applaudissements]
et
j'adore aller me peser
j'adore aller me faisais après des
mozilla j'ai perdu du poids les
vaisseaux est ce qu'on n'est pas trop
intime je vois pas du tout même avis
c'est impossible non mais une fois la
mécanique maintien et d'inclusion
intestinales mici non mais moi je te dis
c'est pas possible c'est plein examen
c'est étonnamment
suit l'état
petit oiseau de bon aloi chez elle par m
même les oiseaux ils chient des graines
à
savoir qu'elle se souvient pu en fait
côté a réussi ça c'est plus que tout
part dans la couche maintenant pas
encore non moi tous les matins
régulièrement après le petit déjeuner at
il raconté cette anecdote est pourri
j'irai moi tout va bien très
régulièrement comme une sportive de haut
niveau ce que vous avez déjà un problème
ah oui les problèmes
hu a fait pas pipi caca mois il s'est en
fait c'est ici c'est les fous rires tout
commence avec guillaume jannez spasmes
sous le bureau alors il a les jambes qui
tremblent et l'envoie là et je l'entends
il essaie de retenir un temps de répit
et alors là j'ai en ligne de mire
benjamin castaldi connais bien rouge
congestionné les yeux qui se ferme
et surtout je me dis il faut pas que je
regarde cyril il faut pas je regarde
bien il faut pas que j'écoute guillaume
et la sécurité c'est vrai que c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir un fou rire quand
il faut pas rire amer ignoreraient
qu'elles c'est la pire dans les foules
ne peux pas la regarder et c'est la pire
oui qu'est-ce qu'il est injuste moi je
me savais une chose terrible mais tu
arrives dans un hôtel c'est quand on a
un premier rendez vous avec une jeune
femme et qu'on se rend compte qu
effectivement la porte des toilettes et
près de la shanghai en deux pour toi
alors il ya longtemps et elle et
éviterez à deux mois
vitré du sable en haut il ya un espace
et en bail un espace journée vous avez
été dans quel hôtel mou c'était un hôtel
sympathique en normandie ou dans l
adresse est bref et dont je vous dit
comment je vais aller aux toilettes
parce que forcément comme la dame est à
côté que je dois les autonet d'enceinte
haut sur les toilettes forcément parfois
il ya des petits bruits je me dis
comment je vais faire
j'ai inventé un système qui n'a pas
fonctionné mais je vais prendre du
papier toilette annonce à oui et je
viens de ce possible du silencieux n'a
bien sûr
et en fait ça ne fonctionne pas du tout
à ça que j'ai mis mon papier
intéressant est professeur petit fils
bruit et partir comme ça c'était
terrible alors et à la barre toi là
c'est sapad vraiment temps que la dame
voilà encore enfin ça fait parti d'un
divorce non non non non non c'est une
escapade bomba très bien ce à dire
propos de bigorre ce petit point très
important essayer de ne pas aller aux
toilettes quand vous êtes en couple aux
mêmes horaires systématiquement un choix
parce que ça agace les gens s'éveillent
ap il appelle son petit dilapidé
toilettes ça crée des habitudes ya des
maisons
sorties parfois lors des tribunaux non
bien sûr
ça va juste aller avec fabrice desvignes
qui guette tous les matins bien sûr la
famille delpy contre la famille de leur
mort
vous lui reprochez eux
mahdi dalé chier donc à médicale
l'émission de jean-luc reichman ce qui
vous dérange non mais t'es complètement
fou de vous le dire mais non ma marque
il a raison mais c'est merci croyez moi
par exemple parce que nous on est une
trentaine de livreur a changé dans le
vestiaire le matin on a des vestiaires
il ya des toilettes en enfilade est un
remake à 6h03 il se pose pour faire popo
en même temps mais ça pète dans tous les
sens
[Applaudissements]
des mécaniques mes collègues je vous
allez certainement quitter c'est
vrai ils se parlent de toilettes à
toilettes et en a un qui s est l'outil
tête et vous avez entendu quand vous le
bruit que ça fait c'est horrible toi tu
viens prendre ton kid est en train de
changer pour aller bosser et à faire à
sa 5 6 mecs qui sont en concert ses
gains sans déconner et si la raison 6h03
les met sur les matins 16h03 tel saint
louis dès le vie de merde je veux
reproduire là dessus oui non je voudrais
penser à un truc une anecdote qui était
horrible pour moi et la lgv est là hélas
anniversaire c'est la banda
giraud tapisser les toilettes oui en
fait on est allé manger chez des clients
avec mon ami steve que vous aviez vu la
dernière fois ok vraiment mon acolyte et
chez ces gens-là leurs deux enfants
était vraiment fan de blanche donc il
était à fond sur moi pendant tout le
repas et blanche de fort boyard blanche
et à l'apéritif déjà je sens que je
commence à avoir mal au ventre la sauce
anomalies là on leur avait surtout la
boule noire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et donc là je dis excusez moi ils sont
où vos toilettes donc on va les
toilettes hélas le ''petit forcément il
est fan izay harmattan h la compagnie
touche
il m'accompagne donc déjà donc je vais
aux toilettes j'ai aux toilettes et là
il continue à parler de fort boyard à
travers la porte derrière moi c'est un
peu compliqué donc forcément je tire la
chasse de rien du tout je reviens je
commence nous alors mal au ventre et
tout le truc continue 20 minutes après
je dis excusez moi je retourne toilettes
donc là je retourne aux toilettes et la
ba voila je fais comme s'il n'était pas
là mais au bout de deux minutes il toque
il fait c'est bon t'as bientôt fini j'ai
fait un dessin pour toi tu viens donc là
forcément c'est compliqué donc je suis
toujours pas de toilettes hockey est
donc là je leur dit écoutez j'ai pas de
réseau dans votre maison est ce que je
peux aller dehors parce que la gt car
est allé dehors non mais tellement que
je suis en campagne bah ouais sauf que
quand j'ai alors il dit ne va pas de
hoerdt inquiète pas j'ai du wifi tu peux
rester à l'intérieur fait non non mais
je vais aller dehors j'arrive dehors il
fait nuit et tout d'un coup j'arrive
d'heure et là les spots c'était une très
belle maison
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est très drôle et là je commence à
avoir la goutte comme ça donc qu'est ce
que je fais je prends mon téléphone j'ai
créé à mon pote steve et je fais steve
on se barre je me sens vraiment trop mal
mais effectivement dans ce patelin y
avait pas de réseau donc le message non
distribués en eau donc j'étais hyper mal
donc là je rentre dans la maison je
festive on va bientôt y aller et tout
lui il était en train de trinquer tout
macha était pas du tout dans le délire
et là je fais écouter on va vraiment y
aller hélas le ''petit fait ben non
attends je veux montrer mon dessin alors
il sort son dessin son petit job
sort sans grand dessein il n 10 alors là
c'est toi la socan données et le dessin
c'était une feuille à 2 quoi il me
montre tout son truc et moi vraiment
j'avance je commençais à avoir les
larmes aux yeux tellement qu'il fallait
que ça soit bon une fois que c'était
fini chez bon allez on y va hélas sa
grande soeur et bien non moi aussi je te
fais un dessin et aime le monde possède
désormais un concept
et voilà c'était horrible
belle à la chute qu'elle accueille aller
aux urgences et amandes j'étais mal vous
avez été vous avez pu aller aux arrivées
à bon port mais je pense que j'ai dû
faire une allergie j'avais mal au ventre
après je veux plus respirer j'ai demandé
à steve demandé aux urgences après au
final c'est les urgences qui ont pris
alors il ya beaucoup de témoignages sur
ce débat sachez le mes n'aura notre
chéri et nora qui me met frère tu te
souviens quand toi tu avais hier dans la
chambre de jean rachid merci n'aura de
me rappeler les bons souvenirs